what what what so you're at a party are
you that girl that gets way too drunk
and ends up with gaps in our memory the
next morning or are you that person that
doesn't really know anyone so you kind
of stand in the corner all cool and
nonchalant like or maybe just maybe
you're the life of the party
you're that cool guy that everyone wants
to hang around but let's face it this is
the Internet none of us are this person
I hate parties I have rarely had a good
experience at one eye I either get
nervous and drink too much all right
I'm will or I don't know anyone so I end
up slipping out and leaving early
sometimes I don't even make it to the
party I get to the front door and skip
to the part where I run away because
let's face the facts what is the point
of parties you go there to either drink
your pain away party your pain away or
hook up with someone so that your pain
can be accompanied by the side of self
disgust look don't get me wrong I'm all
for trying new things and getting out
there and being social but you also have
to be selective you have to be smart
about it
surrounding yourself with people that
you want to be like because the
direction that your life goes not only
depends on you but the places you decide
to spend your time